when a great talent is on screen you
don't see the actress only the character
she's become you see a former first lady
a Civil Rights icon a rape victim an
untalented heiress or a young woman with
big dreams the artist who's brought
those characters to life are our
nominees for performance by an actress
and a leading role Isabel who pair L
weeks mega loving Natalie Portman Jackie
emma stone lala land Meryl Streep
Florence foster Jenkins
and the Oscar goes to Emma Stone lalala
this is the first Oscar and second
nomination for Emma Stone she was
previously nominated for her supporting
role in Birdman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much to the Academy to the
women in this category Natalie Isabelle
Merrill Ruth he were all so
extraordinary and I look up to you and I
admire you more than I can put into
words it's been the greatest honor
justice channel on side year that is the
greatest honor of all to my mom and my
dad and my brother Spencer and my soul
sister Kristy and my whole family I love
you so much thank you for everything
into Doug Wald who stood by me all these
years and to Holly and Michele and Craig
and PJ and Greta and Bob Cooper thank
you so much and I realize at a moment
like this is a huge confluence of luck
and opportunity and so I want to thank
Damien Chazelle for the opportunity to
be part of a project that was so special
and once-in-a-lifetime I'm so grateful
to have been involved in this film and
thank you for your faith and your
patience and such a wonderful experience
and Ryan Gosling thank you for making me
laugh and for always raising the bar and
for being the greatest partner on this
crazy adventure to our whole crew
everyone that put their heart and souls
into this film I I'm going to find you
all individually and I'm going to thank
you along with my friends who I love so
much I'm going to hug the hell out of
you when the feelings re-enters my body
I I still have a lot of growing and
learning and work to do and this guy is
a really beautiful symbol to continue on
that journey and I'm so grateful for
that so thank you so much thank you
[Applause]